[Music]
kevin you've uh you've been in this
business uh a long time you've uh how
long do you think i've been in this
business i'm gonna go with uh 31 years
that's pretty accurate yeah uh
good guess i have google under the desk
uh i was like
google iv i do uh you've met so many
celebrities is there any celebrity that
just left you awestruck where you were
intimidated you and at this point i
can't imagine there is good question
these are all good questions by the way
that's
this is the one you do your research
yeah yeah i asked the ones you told me
to ask you uh
what
um
uh well what am i somebody who's left
you star struck and i really mean that
this is my own i'm just free styling
here i understand i have been in this
business for 31 years approximately yeah
yeah um and um nobody has really
intimidated me except for jack nicholson
sure yeah and i finally get to meet him
i it was an adam sandler film i do quite
a few adam sandler films he's a good
friend so i'm in anger management and
jack nicholson's in it and i'm like
freaking out there's jack nicholson you
know and he's sitting across from me at
the first rehearsal and then afterwards
i go over to introduce myself and i was
really nervous and he was talking to
sandler and i thought i'm going to go
over there i got to do it because it's
jack nicholson and i finally got the
courage i went over there my heart's
beating like a million miles an hour and
i tap him on the shoulder i said hey
jack have you uh have you been golfing
over at um my mouth is dry have you been
uh like sherwood lately because i knew
he's a member there and he said what
and sandler's laughing behind him like
and i said have you have you been have
you been golfing over lake sherwood
lately he said not since the last time
he asked me that question
and now i'm thinking on sandler's really
laughing now and i'm thinking
what did he mean by that i never
uh maybe i asked him this question like
a year ago and i didn't remember right
and then i thought well maybe he's
referring to the time i just asked about
that
yeah he was trying to be funny yeah i
analyzed his answer for like a year
after that
you know i would be driving places i'd
pull over i think i wonder what he meant
when he said that
so cut to like a year later
uh
i had the opportunity to meet him again
and um i was at this very fancy
hollywood party everybody was there
i mean it was like the hollywood wax
museum christopher walken harrison ford
al pacino
elizabeth taylor was there princess leia
george lucas
uh harrison ford uh christopher walken
yeah princess leia yeah al pacino was
there just repeating phil was there okay
i mean everybody elizabeth taylor
hearing them again so um
and i see jack nicholson in the middle
of the room i thought oh my god this is
my chance to redeem myself i'm going to
go over there and reintroduce myself and
do it right this time and i'm waiting
and i'm waiting just for that right
window getting my courage up i'd be a
good assassin because i know how to wait
for the right moment and um so i finally
go i gotta go i gotta go so i'm going
i'm walking past walking and uh
harrison ford leia you know all those
people
and i finally come up to uh jack
nicholson and i tap him on the shoulder
he turns around
i said hey jack
you've been um golfing i'll put um
over at dao
and then right then al pacino tapped him
on the shoulder and jack nicholson
totally turned his back to me and
started talking to al pacino so i'm just
like looking at his back now he totally
snubbed me you know it was like it
looked like i was waiting in line to
talk to al pacino but i wasn't i wasn't
i didn't care about the kino i didn't
care nicholson was my guy yeah yeah and
you know i was so humiliated by all this
and
i must have something to eat that day
that didn't agree with me
and um
i crop dusted jack nicholson right there
gas on the go gas on the go
and um
well thank you very much thank you
thank you appreciate it thank you but um
i think pacino caught a little bit of
the fallout to be honest with you
so it's a two for one right there
and then i'm walking back i'm walking i
get back to the uh where i started from
because yeah because it was bad and i'm
passing walking forward leia i get back
uh pacino yeah uh taylor and i get back
to my original spot and i'm standing on
thinking this is not going to be good
and in the middle of his conversation
with pacino he stops and he goes
jeez what the hell died in here
and i thought that's the last time he's
ever going to snub me like that
you
yes
[Applause]